here at eight news now we know the
rising price of gas groceries really
everything they're all impacting our
viewers to help out and give back to our
community eight news now has partnered
with albertsons to help gift you a good
day so every week we surprise one of our
lucky shoppers and help to pay for their
groceries so let's take a look at how i
surprised one albertson shopper
i met ralph at the albertson's near
silverado ranch he's a former clark
county school district counselor he told
me his dollars aren't going as far as
they used to we just kind of make do
with it
ralph says both he and his wife are
retired from the school district but
they often still have a full house next
door i have my daughter her husband and
my three grandchildren oh boy so we
spend a lot of time together
and we share a lot of meals together
and
when i shop it's
taking them into account also you have
to uh
we moderate going out and don't don't
eat out as often as we used to before
that's when we decided to gift ralph a
good day well what if i told you that we
would like to
gift you a good day today okay
albertsons and eight news now would like
to buy your groceries today ralph
thank you
that's really a big help thank you very
much that's very nice well you take care
of your family and we'd like to help
take care of you well thank you very
much i appreciate it all of you thank
you you've given back a lot of years to
our community to our kids and we'd like
to help you out a little bit and say
thank you well thank you we appreciate
it
[Music]
did ralph look confused he was like
what's happening right now ralph was so
wonderful very appreciative i had a
great time surprising him and you never
know could be you next keep an eye out
for one of us here on the good day team
and maybe you'll be the next person to
be gifted a good day
i love drought and you said
his look is priceless when he's like
what is happening to me right now yeah
he's like trying to
detect what you're talking about here
his counselor experience coming in oh
you're helping us not so sure about this
lady here
but it all worked out in the end yes
you're helping stock hotel ralph
yes for all the guests who come exactly
you know and we see that a lot i don't
know about you guys but when i'm talking
to folks it's fine i find out it's not
just their household they still have
family coming in to feed and to to
entertain and to share meals with and i
think a lot of that really started
during the pandemic a lot of people were
staying close to home you know you
weren't going out to eat and
so it gets a little pricey when when the
fam is coming back over for dinner a lot
during the pandemic you realize how
important those connections were so i
think we added that back in which is
nice you bet so congrats ralph and we
appreciate all you've done in your wife
for the school district all those years